if you've been on the internet recently
you've seen these beautiful
silver balls they're mesmerizing to look
at
and they are actually made out of
aluminum foil
apparently it takes hours to do i think
when people here
shove aluminum together hammer it and
then sand it they think any idiot could
do that so
i'm the idiot that's going to do that
my strategy is to take
a blob of tin foil shove it into a ball
hammer it sand it how hard can it be
i hope this isn't poison are you [ __ ]
kidding me stupid space
rock why did i think i could do this
let's do it i feel like go big or go
home right
because when you hammer it it's going to
get much smaller so
this is a big boy this is the ball we're
starting with it's kind of like how you
turn
carbon into a diamond and then it's
something beautiful
it might take hours no one has to stay
you don't have to say
it start in japan which i think is where
most cool things start
feels good hit things i have to compress
it
before i can smooth it you kind of see i
kind of started to make this area
circular
minutes it's actually been eight minutes
eight minutes
are you [ __ ] kidding me
it's kind of like an indent right there
so my next goal is to make this
into an actual fear i'm trying to pet
myself up kids can do this i can do this
i'm an adult
the roll and the smushing
is probably the most important step and
i think i [ __ ] it up
still going to try to salvage this you
know what i need ashley
ashley does a lot of diy stuff so i'm
going to find her
look at that balloon it's just like
bragging about how round it is
ashley this is where i am and is there
any way to salvage this
it's not going to be a sphere i think
you can get it to like an egg shape egg
i haven't seen that yet this is a
professional ball
shaper myself you can't see it getting
any further than that oh no
harder than it looks i guess will you oh
i'm gonna fall
more aggressive maybe you take a little
bit off in there just chop the head off
so it's a little bit more ball-esque
thank you
no one's being very helpful you know
what i'm gonna take this basketball
i'm gonna take it and use it as inspo
this isn't a ball
and it looks bad but good news we got in
touch
with the guy who basically created the
whole phenomenon
he can tell me exactly how to do this
well he speaks japanese and i don't but
not a problem because we have people
buzzfeed who can translate
for me and while we wait for that i'm
gonna keep going
and do my own research oh he's showing
us how to do it
yeah hammer as you enroll all right
we're starting over okay under this
system
we pull it out fold it like this
we hold it like a triangle and then we
roll it in we kind of crunch it in
we start the ball here people do a
little hammering as we go
oh jesus this is an important step
people
see things online and think yeah i can
do that
and they can't but maybe if they fail
enough they can
i'm starting with something that's a lot
more of a ball shape
my faith is restored because this looks
pretty good i'm gonna move on
to stage two which is sanding
i think you start coarser and go finer
so we're gonna start with an 80 and then
go to 220.
so it's looking pretty good before when
i was doing this people would walk by
they had no idea what i was doing
now people walk by and they're like oh
the thing you put in the microwave
my silver hands
[Applause]
yeah it's a ball thank you
don't give up forever
what grit sandpaper are you guys using i
don't know
once you get to the thousands those are
the really fine and that's what you're
gonna get your shine out of we only see
so
you probably want to get like 1500 grit
because then you wet it up a little bit
and then they kind of like
oh there's such a thing as yeah wet
sanding
[Music]
do you want me to go get the 1500
so now we've got the 2000
and the 1500 and so now we should be
able to actually make
this ball smooth you think i dip this in
and then sand
where it's wet so i'm going to get a
little wet
and then we're sanding
[Music]
i do see it working five hours in
i'm not there yet this takes forever to
do
this project is not for the faint of
heart i mean it really is
starting to look pretty cool it's just
that i'm tired of doing it all right
i'm gonna pause this stuff so you don't
oh
yeah i guess you can cut off it's day
two and i'm back trying to make a ball
of foil
shinier than it needs to be oh
that's the sound of my microwave looks
like it's done
wow there you have it
and that's how i'm just kidding don't do
that don't put your
foil ball in the microwave that's a
really bad idea a very funny tweet but a
really
bad idea i spent all of last night sandy
i actually googled like a hand workout
my hands never hurt so much
sanding brad's cooking dinner and i'm
trying to make my balls shiny
still sanding hopefully it'll be good
enough to polish tomorrow morning
hopefully and we're going to shortly
move on to polishing
we got a shiny ball and we're going to
make it shinier
let's do this ooh creamy
so we're going to do this a little bit
and i might sand with it too because
that was one of the tips we picked up
online to maybe try to oh my god
the smell is overpowering how do people
work oh god
so we got a little bit of that on there
i'm polishing and sanding together
because that's something i saw online
it's not the kind of smell you really
want to inhale can you smell it
no okay that's good at least it's just
me i'm sweating again
diy is a workout but like this shiny
ball is a real workout
yes you can what what
yeah so max just told me that we
finally have communicated with the
originator of the tin foil ball my
co-worker sarah was able to translate it
so we're gonna go talk to her
yeah i know i am almost done my ball but
figured better late than never let's
find out what he says
it says my younger brother developed the
method of making aluminum foil balls
himself i usually make clockwork dolls i
make aluminum foil balls as part of that
work you can make an aluminum foil
ball in like an hour to an hour and a
half the only tool necessary
is a hammer no um he doesn't use any
kind of abrasive
hit it a bunch of times really hard with
a hammer um the aluminum foil will turn
into one mass with no
uh gaps in between it turns out i wasted
hours
maybe even days doing it a more
complicated way but you know what
so gonna finish it at the end i'll make
me feel proud but right now i just feel
angry
now i'm back to polishing let's do it
let's do it [ __ ]
i'll do a little bit more and now i have
to go with a dry cloth
and wipe it down and hopefully this will
be the last
beautiful pristine version of my shiny
ball
i feel so accomplished i'm proud looks
good right
this was my first attempt and now i'm
here i got a shiny ball
if i had a buffing machine and it would
have been perfect but with my hands
which are in pain i did this things
might look easy to do
online it might look like you just take
tin foil smoosh it into a ball
buff it and there you go but that's not
the case
you need to do your research you need to
see what other people are doing the
mistakes they've made so you don't make
the same mistakes
so i hope you have a better idea of how
to do it or if you're like me and have
your friends that are good at diy
make this for you and pay them a lot of
money because it will take
hours to make it's kind of like a ooh
crystal ball
not it's not that shiny but don't they
do this
am i doing the right thing oh what do i
see in your future
probably like a lot of blisters on your
hands
because you made this ball